John Ritter played Kaley Cuoco's father
on the sitcom eight simple rules for
dating my teenage daughter and while
they weren't actually related he still
felt like a father figure to her his
untimely death due to complications with
a heart condition left her feeling lost
and today she still thinks about him all
the time kuoko couldn't believe that
Ritter was gone and the cast addressed
his death in a touching episode of eight
simple rules Cuoco continued moving
forward in her acting career Landing a
major role as Penny on The Big Bang
Theory but she never forgot about her
wonderful experiences of working with
Ritter on the 15th anniversary of his
death in 2018 she revealed that there
isn't a day that goes by when her
memories with Ritter don't make her
laugh at the same time she still Mourns
his loss her Big Bang Theory co-star Jim
Parsons said I don't think she ever
talks about him without tears in her
eyes she's emotionally stable but there
was definitely a fatherly Bond